Magnus Carlson comboed four great moves
and a brilliancy to take home an
incredible comeback victory in today's
Armageddon match on day two of Norway
chess the former world champion faced
American Wesley so coming off of a loss
Magnus needed to turn the tide the
classical game ended in a draw but it
was in Armageddon where the match heated
up Wesley started to press the advantage
turning it into a hopeless situation for
Magnus who would still lose with a draw
under Armageddon rules but Wesley began
to worry about the time making
ill-advised moves and putting his King
in danger the black king
might be in huge trouble he goes back
it was at this moment that Magnus did
what he does best very risky game but he
gets away with it and he merges with a
win in Armageddon after the match Magnus
had this to say the game that I won was
pretty poor but uh getting to to attack
him was was fun rolling down on Uno
reverse card